[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we'll
be talking about the multiple epic
showdowns that are currently underway in
the seven deadly sins manga including
friend against friend father against son
and Mellie Otis against himself all at
the same time the last few arcs of the
seven deadly sins story have been so
intense and the intensity just keeps
going up so I'm gonna have to keep
making these videos because I need to
share my excitement with you guys and I
really want to get a good conversation
going I can't help wanting to talk about
what is happening right now and what is
going to happen next in the story before
we get started I want to give a quick
thank you to final blade for sponsoring
this video we all know how unstable the
life of a youtuber can be with the
monetization and false copyright claims
in fact I just got one of those the
other day on my shield hero video so it
really means a lot when someone is
willing to support this channel and
final blade is doing just that
final blade is a mobile fantasy RPG that
is clearly inspired by anime and set in
a magical world based on the Magnificent
cultures of the Far East the game has
impressive graphics and excellent
English voice acting and the in-game
guide makes it very easy to get started
once you get into the game the action is
fast paced the soundtrack is beautiful
and there are over 300 characters you
can choose from you recruit your own
team of badass heroes with unique
weapons and skills and you can use them
to play an adventure mode or to duel
other players online and if you are
looking for a fun game to play right now
is the perfect time to start they just
had their valentine event which included
a special item drop and a limited
edition hero and there will of course be
more events in the future including more
limited edition heroes and more special
items please show final blade some love
by clicking the link in the description
and tried to game out for yourself it's
free to play on Android and iOS needless
to say this video will be talking about
the latest events in the seven deadly
sins manga so if you're an anime only
fan proceed with caution
manga spoilers ahead chapter 301 starts
off as bond rescues Hawke who has been
basically reduced to bacon at this point
but bond tosses him to safety before
face
off against the demon king in
melioidosis body King warns bond that
even with his immortality he doesn't
stand a chance against the demon king on
his own but bought answers that he isn't
even immortal anymore because he gave up
his immortality in order to permanently
revive Alain everyone looks at bond as
if he's crazy to think that he can stand
against the demon king after the demon
king rekt everyone on his own without
even breaking a sweat
in the last chapter as the battle begins
the demon king creates a massive toxic
storm that no living beings should be
able to withstand without some sort of
magical protection but the storm doesn't
even faze bond and he says that compared
to the harsh climate of purgatory this
storm is just an adorable little breeze
bonds new power and durability shocks
everyone including the demon king and an
epic battle begins as bond manages to
actually go blow-for-blow with the demon
king all on his own when we considered a
fact that mile with sunshine king with
his new power up merlin ludo shell and
the others couldn't really do anything
to the demon king as a team then it
becomes clear that bonds new power is
truly on another level and it certainly
makes bonds power before he entered
purgatory look like a joke if you want
to know more about bonds power up and
exactly how strong he might actually be
at this point you can check out our
video called how strong is bond after
purgatory my brother goes and who runs
this channel with me did an excellent
job in my opinion of taking all of bonds
abilities into consideration in order to
give us a better understanding of bonds
newfound power I will link to that video
in the description so feel free to check
it out at this point I have to mention
that during his showdown with bond the
demon king refers to himself as a god
which is very interesting to me we don't
know very much about the demon king or
the supreme deity other than the fact
that they are rulers of their respective
clans and the strongest members of these
clans however I know by looking at your
comments that a lot of you guys have
been wondering whether the demon king
and the supreme deity are not just the
rulers and strongest members of their
clans but rather something more are they
actually some type of divine beings such
as a god I've been thinking about these
questions myself what is the true nature
and origin of these two incredibly
powerful creatures and how will the
truth about them imp
the rest of the story I'm actually
thinking about making a special video on
the demon king and the supreme deity in
particular so if you'd like to see me
make that video leave a hashtag supreme
hype in the chat to let me know if we
get a bunch of comments about it then I
will definitely make that video and
don't forget that I do read the comments
even if I can't respond to them all so
your feedback and your requests do
matter as the intense struggle between
bond and the demon king rages on the
demon king gains the upper hand and he
then proceeds to mock bond for thinking
that he could ever stand against the
demon king so at this point we see that
as strong as bond is and he is clearly
insanely strong right now he still can't
overpower the demon king on his own and
that does make sense with how strong the
demon king is believed to be and for how
long he was able to resist the joint
attacks of melee Otis's emotions bond
and wild the back in purgatory it would
be a bit unrealistic to believe that
bond would now suddenly be able to take
him out on his own however it is at this
point that bond tells the demon king
that he is not on his own after all and
in that moment the real meliodas
that is his true emotions that have been
finally liberated from purgatory
returned to his body and an internal
struggle begins between melioidosis
emotions of the real meliodas and the
demon king it is a fight for control
over Mele Otis's newly powered up
physical body as part of the internal
struggle the demon king says to meliodas
that bringing about fear and death is
his duty his very existence and in a
memorable one-liner meliodas answers
that this is the demon king sin and so a
truly epic double showdown is set up for
us the external battle between bond and
the demon king who was inside
melioidosis physical body and the
internal battle between Mele Otis's
emotions and the demon king both of
these are about to unfold at the same
time in front of our very eyes this was
another remarkable chapter and the hype
just continues to build for this amazing
series we now have an insanely powerful
bond fighting against the demon king
possessed meliodas in the physical world
we have the real Mele Otis engaging in
an internal struggle against the demon
Kings control of his physical body and
we have other incredibly powerful
character
like zelgius smile with sunshine Merlin
King in his new form and all the others
just watching from the sidelines and
there is still the question of the demon
king and the supreme deity in their
original bodies even if millie oda
succeeds in regaining control of his
body what will happen with the demon
king and the supreme deity will Mele
Otis and the sins just leave them to
continue plotting their holy wars as
usual or will they have to take the
battle to these two powerful beings in
order to stop further Wars and suffering
from occurring if the demon king in his
original body and the supreme deity
still have to be confronted then this
current arc where the demon king is
controlling meliodas body cannot be the
end we know that the demon king is still
out there somewhere in purgatory and we
don't know hardly anything about the
supreme deity other than the fact that
she is supremely
opie and that she resides in the
celestial realm and as a matter of fact
we know basically nothing about either
the celestial realm or the demon realm I
have a ton of questions about these
characters and about the celestial and
demon realms so I do hope that naka
bouzouki won't rush the story and that
he will give us a thorough and
satisfying resolution I know that a ton
of people are talking about how the
seven deadly sins manga is supposed to
end very soon and you can definitely say
that the story has been ratcheting up
and building hype for an epic conclusion
personally I won't lie I hope it doesn't
end soon even though it likely will
because I'm just enjoying it so much the
manga right now is better than ever and
I don't want it to stop I feel like the
world of the seven deadly sins has
established it's just so interesting and
there's so much more that we could
explore different kingdoms different
realms different legendary swords or
other weapons like Excalibur different
races or mythological creatures the
mother of chaos being a prime example
there are just so many unsolved
mysteries in this series that still need
to be resolved from the origins of the
demon king of the supreme deity to the
full details of the original goal Thurs
plan to the ultimate fate of Arthur and
the legendary sword Excalibur and yes I
know that a lot of people think that
Arthur is just dead and gone forever but
I just don't buy it not when we know
that the seven deadly sins is so heavily
inspired by Arthurian legend and the
main character of Arthurian legend is
none other than King Arthur okay
but let me know what you guys think how
are you enjoying these recent arts in
the manga and what do you think will
happen next
will bond and meliodas succeed in
exercising the demon king from le Otis's
body or will the demon king foil their
plans will this be the final battle of
the series or are we going to see the
story shift towards the demon king and
the supreme deity and the demon and
celestial realms please feel free to
give me your thoughts and feedback down
below important news we now stream live
discussions of the seven deadly sins
chapters as they come out on our twitch
channel twitch.tv slash anime uproar if
you want to join the discussions in QA
live just follow us on Twitch link in
the description you can tune in on
wednesdays at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time
also known as East Coast time in North
America if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell be sure
to check out our sponsor final blade you
can play the game for free link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching I really appreciate it
and until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]